let's go to rachel we're trying to
figure out where to socially distance
mike come on
i'm standing with tyler hero you are 20
years old do you know that only one
other man in nba history
has scored the points you have at this
age in a playoff game and that is magic
johnson in 1980.
how do you feel about that and what you
did here tonight
uh i mean i feel good about it you know
there's a lot of work to be done
uh still you know we're up 3-1 big win
for us tonight
you know we felt like we could have won
game three came out with more energy
tonight
um you know credit to my teammates and
coaches that we
you know we put a lot of time and effort
into it uh preparing for game four and
we got ready and we got the job done
there is no situation that seemed too
big for you
your swagger according to your teammates
is off the charts
i was watching a highlight for you in
college and you said to the rest of the
people on the court
i'm a bucket yeah where did this come
from uh
i mean that's just who i am you know i
grew up like that and i'm gonna stay
like that for as long as i'm in the
league but
you know it's just a good win for us
tonight you guys are now up
3-1 one win away from the nba finals
what do you need to do to close this
series out
uh just get ready for you know the next
game there's gonna be a lot of
adjustments made on both ends
um you know each game is different you
know each game could be a different
score every night and uh
you know next game is going to be a big
one for us thank you so much tyler a lot
of fun to see you out there tonight
a lot of fun down here mike back to you